et d'abord donc les premiers instants de
liberté de patrick dils 7 et hier soit
deux heures après son acquittement une
sortie de prison un peu mouvementée
après 15 ans passés derrière les
barreaux
tout le monde voulait entendre les
premiers mots de celui qui incarne
désormais l'une des plus graves erreurs
judiciaires en france
stéphanie perez et jérémie drieu à lyon
c'est un garçon à gars qui sort de
prison comme un enfant patrick dils se
laisse guider par ses avocats
il vient de passer 15 ans derrière les
barreaux et face à la meute de
journalistes son premier contact avec
l'extérieur est plutôt rude en place ont
fait tomber j'ai eu du mal à respirer et
puis j'ai compris que moi je me suis
pris une seule ride
se retrouver devant situation que
j'attendais depuis 15 ans voilà quelque
part je suis noyé plus raison avec lui
pourquoi aujourd'hui il alors et ç'a
toujours été là mais jamais les voilà
comme je viens de le dire je veux
retrouver ma famille je pas retrouvé mes
amis lavail à jouer et leur poser
lorsque shaïek ce reportage
je suis celui à qui l'on a reproché de
ne jamais avoir trouvé les mots justes
pour se défendre ces quinze dernières
années parlent enfin avec son coeur il
veut penser à l'avenir
rien qu'à l'avenir je vais découvrir un
petit régional et pas question de faire
une nouvelle délégation de faire tout
simplement parce que j'ai pas vécu je
leur ai jamais ses anges
deux heures plus tôt le comité de
soutien au 10 avait accueilli le verdict
avec un tonnerre d'applaudissements
l'ambiance est un peu folle la famille
dils pleurs le père de patrick a fait un
malaise il titube may cry sa délivrance
le plus innocent enfin on va pouvoir
respirer enfin on va pouvoir serrer
patrick dans nos bras là on va pouvoir
attraper 15 ans mon frangin j'écoutais
j'avais 13 ans
acclamé les deux avocats de deals
savourent leur victoire leur plaidoirie
hier ont fini de convaincre la cour
ils en sont persuadés francis heaulme
est le meurtrier
l'erreur judiciaire qu'il dénonçait est
reconnu mais il leur aura fallu trois
procès
j'aime beaucoup davantage pour
reconnaître que dans la patrie des
droits de l'homme
quelqu'un est bien fermée pendant 16 ans
alors qu'il était devant le courage la
cour d'assises du rhône là réside la
famille dils ne se retrouvera pas seul
tout de suite une grande chaîne privée
acheté l'exclusivité de leurs
retrouvailles bien plus vite qu'il ne
l'avait sûrement imaginer patrick dils
bien d'être confronté à une première
réalité la réalité médiatique